welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the mandalorian season 2 just
reached out in its biggest way yet to
the star wars universe network of
jedi a link that many believe may have
been made with luke skywalker since the
mandalorian is set five years or so
after return of the jedi we know
luke is alive somewhere in the galaxy
and thanks to ahsoka tano's guidance to
track down other jedi
via the taithon seeing stone that leaves
very few
other jedi grogu could have connected
with yes presumably ezra bridger is out
there
calcast is from jedi fallen order maybe
sidious maybe jeans guy
but i'm gonna explain based on what we
know about luke's history during this
period
and subtle clues in the recent
mandalorian episode why
a cameo by mark hamill luke skywalker
might be
the most likely scenario that i will
never have to own up as a mistake
let's remind ourselves where luke is at
this period the mandalorian is set in
nine aby
about five years after the battle of
endor four years after the empire's
seemingly final rout in the battle of
jakku
the new republic has established a new
government on chandrila
and in this period various x-wing pilots
now patrol the galaxy trying to
establish new republic footing
in the outer rim worlds they are worried
about a growing threat there though
but in the months between the battle of
endor in the battle of jakku
luke skywalker was training his sister
leia as a jedi we saw this in a
flashback in the rise of skywalker but
then
in 5 aby leia gave birth to her son
ben solo and her priorities shifted no
more jediing
and four years after that are the
present events of the mandalorian luke
is not yet in his exile in notch 2. he's
not even training ben solo yet no new
jedi temple is being built it's still
too early for that his training of ben
solo would not begin until ben was
10 and 15 aby six years from now and
then six years or so after that luke
would fail to find echogal with lando we
saw that in the rise of skywalker too
and then
in 28 aby is when luke fights with ben
solo and loses ben
to the first order and then luke goes
into exile on och 2. but back in 9 aby
we know that luke at this point is on a
vast search for knowledge about the
history of the jedi and the sith he
teams up with lor san tekka max
vonsydow's character from the force
awakens santeka helps luke piece
together the true past of the jedi order
luke's journey takes him to catalinta
as well as the sith home world of
moriban over his time he assembles the
eight jedi texts
sacred jedi texts he thought they bear
into that tree but rey swiped him first
luke during his search period
also finds the personal archives of jedi
temple librarian jocasta new
and learns about jedi masters like mace
windu and qui-gon jinn
as well as dark side warriors like darth
bane darth maul darth tyranus and
inquisitors who punted the jedi during
the galactic civil war we also know from
battlefront 2 that luke had previously
found a compass in the emperor's
observatory on
paleo which is what helped him find his
way to actually to begin with but before
i continue i want to thank our friends
at bessie shoes for sponsoring this
video that sc
makes these knit sneakers that are 100
waterproof and weatherproof they are
super breathable so they don't let any
liquid in but they also let the air move
out
and they have this antimicrobial insole
to keep your foot see smelling good like
keanu reeves good
i bet he smells great i mean we know he
smells breathtaking messy shoes are also
super stretchy they fit like a sock they
only weigh 175 grams which
is less than a roll of quarters and
those are way less comfortable to wear
on your feet these are made with this
cool dynamex material that keeps your
feet warm in cold weather but cool in
warm weather and it's super easy to
clean
and as we head into these snowy and
rainy months it is really really great
to have besties for running errands
around town while keeping your feet warm
and dry and comfy these are really the
perfect just leave them by the front
door shoes that you can wear any day
what do you mean that's what they're
gonna name the next avengers movie uh
oh my shoes are all
wet but hey you know what kevin feige my
feet are bone
dry thanks to these bessie knit sneakers
i'm wearing
you gotta get yourself a pair because
your feet can get as
wet as possible but your toes bone dry
and they have this incredible early
holiday sale offer right now don't
procrastinate and wait to the last
minute to do your holiday shopping this
is the perfect gift for you and your
loved ones especially for the upcoming
rainy season get them while they still
have sizes and you can make me later
check them out in the link below and if
you miss the holiday sale no worries
just use my code new rockstars to get 25
off your investing shoes the most
important detail when it comes to luke's
link with mandalorian
is luke's whole search for the first
jedi temple he was pretty obsessed with
it so during this period he has learned
about the lothal jedi temple and he
obviously knows about ouch too
so presumably he would also know about
this ancient temple on tython
this scene stone that grogu uses has
either already been visited by luke
skywalker
or will soon be discovered by him or was
just discovered by luke
this episode we might have seen it
happen here okay there's a very good
chance luke skywalker would have already
found python folks notice
earlier in this episode that mando's
dashboard display on approach lists
orbesh text which translates to
region core and we learned from that
protocol droid teachers star map back in
chapter 12 that the core worlds
are the location of the new republic's
center of government so tython isn't one
of those
remote hard to find worlds like gotch 2
is python probably would have been one
of the first stops on luke's search
and then upon the stonehenge python clip
top are some visual
clues the butterflies these might be
linked to a darth vader comic in which
vader visualizes himself in his mind's
eye a violent gnarly form except
these blue glowing butterflies flapping
about those represented the light side
of the force still
in him the new hope for that redemption
that
luke and return of the jedi would
inspire so if those butterflies were the
promise of luke
they could be the same thing here on
tithon i've also pointed out that those
butterflies seem to disappear once grogu
has activated the beacon so
maybe they actually transform into that
energy field itself
looking even more closely the beam
blasts up from this ring of runes around
the stone
these runes are written in the old
tongue the sith language but a language
also used by ancient jedi they were on a
sith dagger in the rise of skywalker
rebels animators put them on the temple
of lothal in the ruins of malachor but
at the time
those runes didn't translate really to
anything they're just kind of like
nonsense randomly put in there and many
of the symbols were backwards they were
put in inconsistently this was before
the production designers of the
mandalorian have been
really good at making sure all the
visual text translates into something
which you'll know if you watch my recent
breakdown of chapter 14. i translated
pretty much all of it unfortunately
those production designers and editors
were also
really good at making sure these runes
are too faded to weather down too out of
focus
to make out trust me i spent hours
trying to do this
there is not a single character that
matches to the erkatot alphabet only
lines and shapes that could match parts
of some letters but
a lot of different letters but applying
some in universe logic i speculated in
the breakdown that the
text could translate to the old jedi
code there is no emotion there is peace
there is no ignorance there is knowledge
there is no passion there is serenity
there is no chaos there is harmony there
is no death there is the force
just because those words were so
important to the other ancient jedi
temple we know of the
tree on och 2 which could be heard as
whispers
luring in rey in the last jedi
[Music]
now there was that kind of creepy detail
with the scene stone when mando leaves
to go down to confront boba fett at the
base of the hill behind him
up in the hilltop two figures are
visible in the ring of the stones
assuming one is grogu who
is the other is it the tip of one of
those other stones that's orbiting it no
it's a person and the best suspect is
luke skywalker and even if that's not
the shadow of luke skywalker there grogu
talked to someone and i assume that
person is luke skywalker just because
of the remaining jedi alive in the
galaxy the only one known to be
exploring ancient jedi temples during
this time
and to likely know about tython is luke
but i'm not saying luke is physically
standing on that hilltop but we know
from the last jedi that that guy managed
to project himself
via the force to remote locations he did
that from the cliff cave of achtu
sitting on a similar boulder maybe it's
another seeing stone
now yes while luke was not yet in his
exile to achtube based on him having
already found that compass to it he
could have still been there just on an
earlier visit
scouting it out that remote projection
is how i suspect we
would see luke skywalker this season of
the mandalorian if that does indeed
happen
i don't think we're gonna see a de-aged
mark hamill crystal clear resolution but
kind of creepy in that uncanny valley
kind of way
joining all these characters in the same
exact space by the way i also don't
think we're gonna see those fan pushes
of sebastian stan to play a younger luke
because smash stand is about to appear
on disney plus in the falcon the winner
soldier the platform is going to want
all the attention to go to bucky and not
like cannibalize the attention on one of
their actors with another show but
imagine this a fuzzy blurry
projection of a younger luke that's
flickering in and out of resolution so
we don't really focus on all the little
vfx details this could be something that
he accomplishes before he perfected his
force projection resolution
in the last jedi that might be what that
choppy audio filter from within the
beacon was setting up
hey step out of it we gotta get out of
here
or even more simply folks the voice of
mark hamill could echo
to us soon the sacred jedi texts
speaking to grogu the way obi-wan spoke
to him
either way i'm feeling this season the
mandalorian is going to reveal to us
luke skywalker's exploration of the
history of the jedi by taking us
someplace we have yet to go
inside the mind of the child ooh hey by
the way if you are interested in getting
any of our great mandalorian merch
options at newrockstarsmirch.com
today is the day i would recommend
purchasing that if you want it to be
delivered by christmas just because
right now as far as i know
no shipping company can really guarantee
christmas delivery so if you want one of
these things as a christmas gift for a
loved one which i think they make great
gifts
jump on this right away also subscribe
to new rockstars hit that notification
bell follow me on instagram at eavos
following the rockstars thank you for
watching
i have spoken
[Music]
so